they're throwing stones shoot them it's
a marbenga there shouts at the police
this far-right politician is in occupied
East Jerusalem making a typically
provocative visit into Palestinian
neighborhoods he could soon be a
government minister
there has exploited growing tensions in
Israel's mixed Arab and Jewish towns
fighting fled in these communities last
year after Israel's war with Hamas in
Gaza you have to remember that we had
riots within cities in which Arabs and
Jews are living there were riots there
was a lot of violence uh especially from
the Arab side but there was also Jewish
violence of extremists they were
supported more by people like bengvir
first himself as the friendlier face of
the far right he once advocated the
expulsion of all Palestinians now
bengathir says that's just for those he
deems traitors or terrorists
I want to tell Benjamin Netanyahu that I
love him with the help of God he'll be
the Prime Minister if we are in the
parliament it'll be a full right-wing
government
seventy percent of Israelis now describe
themselves as right wing a trend that is
traced back to the second in tifada or
Palestinian Uprising that began in 2000.
it was a landmark moment for the middle
ground in Israel began to despair of the
prospects of making peace with the
Palestinians now there was this
onslaught of suicide bombings 20 years
ago and nothing really has changed in
the Israeli mindset that would push them
back towards the center or the center
left Israel has become more and more
right wing and the right wing is
becoming more and more of a far right
if Benjamin Netanyahu gets the chance to
form Israel's next government then it'll
be he who decides if the far right will
get its first taste of power
now if the far right gets into
government it wants to allow parliaments
to overturn Supreme Court rulings
chipping away judicial Independence and
it wants to another law on breach of
trust and these are judicial reforms
widely regarded as allowing the
overturning of the corruption cases
Benjamin Netanyahu faces
Bernard Smith Al Jazeera West Jerusalem